this Saturday is National make a
difference day and the goal of this day
whether you do something big or small is
to contribute to the greater good so
Envy energy the sponsors of the segment
are here to show us what contributions
they are making let's welcome to the
show Angel Williams she is the community
relations manager welcome thank you so
what do you guys have planned for this
year so we recognize the fourth Saturday
in October as we make a difference day
but truly we enjoy celebrating it all
month long so throughout the whole month
of October we've been volunteering just
this past Saturday we were with the Boys
and Girls Clubs doing kids day out we
had about 30 employees out there
mentoring youth spending the whole day
with them having some fun activities and
then we've got more on Deck this
Saturday I love how it's a day and
everyone should be you know doing their
part of the Saturday but you guys make
an entire month yeah we our employees
really have a great time with it so this
coming Saturday we're with Rebuilding
Together Again we'll have a group of
another 30 employees out there helping a
senior citizen to renovate their front
yard and backyard so it's like a yard
crash it's a lot of fun for our
employees we've got folks volunteering
at the center this Friday doing food
distribution to the lgbtq community so a
whole slate of activities that really
gets our employees engaged in support of
the community what does that mean to you
when your employees get together and
they're volunteering their time they're
going out and helping the community what
does that mean to you it's a core value
of NV Energy Right all of our employees
really enjoy that service aspect not
only are we there to deliver safe
reliable energy to our customers but
we're here to serve as well it's a
community that we live in as well and we
work in and we're there to serve people
watching right now and I was looking at
the website too though it's a laundry
list of people an organizations that
you're helping out this year someone's
watching can they join you guys and help
out this year how can people help yeah
the best way to to find out that
information is to go to our website
nvenergy.com there's a listing there of
organizations we're supporting
throughout make a difference month
customers can log on and look for those
volunteer opportunities and join with us
when it comes to your your AC is there a
perfect setting you and I always have
this discussion off here what what's
that ideal setting for someone watching
right now we encourage that setting at
78 degrees that ensures that 78 people
are being efficient yes with your energy
consumption and helps keep your bill low
yes I go 66 in there I like I like it
nice and chilly too cold it is but you
have so many different programs too to
help people out when it comes to their
power bill and everything else we do
yeah again on our website our power
shift programs are there to help you
identify ways to save energy and
ultimately save money whole slate of
programs there I love how you're helping
us save money you're keeping our lights
on and you're giving back to the
community which is the biggest thing
that you guys do thank you so much for
for all that you do thank you Angel we
appreciate it now and thank you to Envy
energy for sponsoring this segment for
more information call
702-402-5555 or visit
nvenergy.com Rocky